Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Ich möchte sicherstellen, dass diese Sendung auch dopingfrei hergestellt wird.
Ähm.
We are Fire up in ready to go. Eine neue Etappe äh Logbuch Netz, Politik steht an, ja?
Heute im grünen Trikot.
Ja, du im äh hoffentlich im äh im rosa gepunkteten, ja, also die Bergwertung musst du auf jeden Fall schaffen. Ja, also das kann sich.
Weißes Trikot.
Verschiedenen weißes Trikot. Ist ja.
Du doch, was ich anhabe.
Nee, eigentlich hast du ja gar nichts an. Soll ich das jetzt sagen?
Ja, aber du siehst doch meine meine weiß gebliebene Haut äh zu den braunen Armen.
Hm, hm.
Hm. Naja, aber wir müssen die Illusion hier auf jeden Fall äh aufrecht erhalten, dass hier mit rechten Dingen zugeht und ähm tja,
da könnten wir ja, könnten wir ja auch äh gleich passenderweise mit einem Rechtsthema beginnen. Was hältst du denn davon?
Ja, wir springen zu Niko Herting, dem Rechtsanwalt, den ich äh persönlich kennenlernen durfte im,
Bundestagsausschuss digitale Agenda zu den Sicherheits und Rechtsfragen nach Snowden,
Ähm der hat schon vor einiger Zeit beim Bundesverwaltungsgericht gegen die E-Mail Überwachung des Bundes Nachrichtendienstes äh geklagt
Wir erinnern uns, das nennt sich ja beim BND die strategische Fernmeldekontrolle,
das ist diese, das sind diese ominösen zwanzig Prozent, ja, wo sie halt auch E-Mails überwachen.
Ähm aber irgendwie nicht sagen von wem und was und so, ne? Und ähm,
Rechtsanwalt Hertingen hat also dagegen geklagt, hat gesagt, das ist äh nicht okay. Hier wird äh Artikel zehn Grundgesetz verletzt. Außerdem bin ich Rechtsanwalt, die dürfen das gar nicht.
Und ähm die Klage wurde dann abgewiesen, weil er nicht konkret darlegen konnte,
dass der BND auch tatsächlich seine E-Mails erfasst hatte.
Und ähm dagegen hat er dann äh eine Verfassungsbeschwerde angekündigt, die wird er sicherlich dann jetzt auch irgendwie oft in die Wege leiten. Ähm er brauchte aber natürlich jetzt noch die Urteilsbegründung. Und die Urteilsbegründung ist ganz interessant, weil das Gericht sagt.
Die ist jetzt rausgekommen.
Genau, die ist jetzt, die hat er jetzt.
Ist jetzt sozusagen die die eigentliche News ist, äh dass diese Begründung veröffentlicht wurde.
Genau, die die eigentliche News ist die Begründung. Oder das äh macht das Ding jetzt so schön so paradox, weil sie in ihrer Urteilsbegründung schreiben, dass das Anliegen,
oder die der der das Delikt,
aufgrund dessen er klagt ähm durchaus äh richtig ist und sie sie sagen, also es ist eine Verletzung von Artikel zehn Grundgesetz, was er da vorwirft,
und allein die grundsätzliche Datenerhebung.
Stellt diesen Grundrechtseingriff dar und nicht erst eine anschließende Auswertung oder Filterung, ja? Das heißt, das Gericht sagt.
Entgegen der Argumentation, die wir ja äh vom BND hören und auch von
äh von der von den NSA Vertretern in in diesen Bereichen hören. Das allein schon die Erfassung reicht, also die maschinelle automatisierte Erfassung dieser E-Mails reicht aus zur Verletzung des Briefgeheimnisses
und es ist unerheblich, ob danach noch irgendwelche automatischen Filter sind und ob eventuell,
niemals einen Mensch reinschaut, sondern die Inhalte der E-Mail so automatisch kategorisiert werden und dann irgendwie in die Guten ins Tröpfchen, die schlechten ins Tröpfchen oder Tröpfchen oder was.
Gemacht werden, sondern die alleine die technische Überwachung ist,
Eine Verletzung von Artikel zehn Grundgesetz und Anlass sich da rechtlich zu beschweren, aber.
Er nimmt ja nur an, dass er betroffen ist und deshalb reicht das nicht aus,
Das Schöne bei dieser strategischen Fernmeldekontrolle ist ja, dass alle betroffen sind, aber niemand es beweisen kann.
Es gab ja auch diese schöne ähm,
diese schöne Aktion äh von der Seite überwach mich nicht oder überwacht mich nicht, wo man ähm
quasi den den BND bitten konnte, zu sagen, ich habe eine Diä-Domain, aber das äh ähm ich möchte oder ich habe keine, aber ich bin trotzdem Deutscher, ja. Ähm.
Und ähm,
Da haben sie dann auch so drauf geantwortet und haben gesagt, nee, unsere Filter sind ja sehr, sehr viel komplizierter. Wir sagen dir aber nicht die Details davon, weil das würde ja den Terroristen helfen. Und abgesehen davon wird's dir ja wahrscheinlich helfen, dich irgendwie gerichtlich dagegen zur Wehr zu setzen.
Ja
Das ist jetzt sozusagen überhaupt der der Verdacht so, ja, dass man sozusagen auch deshalb keinerlei Transparenz im Nachhinein herstellt, weil das ja jetzt im Umkehrschluss bedeuten würde, dass jeder, der von einer Überwachungsmaßnahme Kenntnis äh, also,
in Kenntnis gesetzt wird,
die sich aber sozusagen im Nachhinein mehr oder weniger zwangsläufig jetzt auch als äh unrechtmäßig äh herausstellt oder herausstellen könnte, ja, dass er quasi mit dieser Bestätigung, dass man eben,
überwacht worden ist eigentlich genau diesen Lenkrad, diese letzte dieses letzte Detail, um eine Klage dann dagegen auch erfolgreich durchführen zu können.
Genau. Das war übrigens auch äh interessante Parallele,
Der wichtige Punkt bei der Strafanzeige des,
Chaos Computerclubs ähm und zwar einmal in die in Deutschland gestellte und auch die in,
Großbritannien gegen den gestellte, dass man da Individuen haben musste, äh die Grund zu der Annahme hatten, selber betroffen zu sein, weshalb da auch jeweils nicht der
Chaos, Computerclub als Institution, letztendlich auf dem Papier auftritt, äh sondern die Konstanze kurz.
Quasi als stellvertretender Person.
Also Sie als Individuum.
Für den Chaos-Computer-Club oder mit dem Kaas-Computer-Club im äh Rücken, ja? Aber da da bin ich natürlich jetzt dann auch andererseits gespannt, ob nicht diese beiden ähm.
Juristischen Vorgänge, auf auf über diesen ähnlichen äh äh Catch äh Twenty Tool irgendwie zum Ende geführt werden.
Ja, dass man sagt, na ja, beweis doch erstmal, also Grund zu der Annahme haben ja alle. Grund zu der Annahme, dass sie überwacht werden, haben ja alle. Und das wäre ja auch illegal. Aber beweist doch erstmal, dass du überwacht wirst,
Ja, also das ist halt das ist äh das finde ich schon echt schön. Ähm.
Da muss man halt klar machen, dass wir alle Individuen sind.
Ist, ja. Oder wir müssten halt fünf Leute finden, weil dann wäre halt statistisch gesehen mindestens einer davon betroffen, selbst bei dieser zwanzig Prozentzahl, die die der BND dann also ich finde, das das zeigt halt diese,
absolute Paradoxie dieser ganzen Situation.
Ja, muss man vielleicht nochmal kurz erwähnen sollte, weil ich habe so das Gefühl, das hat hast du gerade nicht gesagt. Also dieser Artikel zehn, auf den sich das bezieht, nur für die Leute, die jetzt ihr Grundgesetz ein mal eins nicht
äh beisammen haben, ist halt im Kern die Aussage, dass Briefgeheimnis sowie das Post- und Fernmeldegeheimnis sind und verletzlich.
Es ist Absatz eins und ab Tag zwei besagt halt Beschränkungen dürfen nur aufgrund eines Gesetzes angeordnet werden et cetera.
Das ist sozusagen hier festgestellt worden. Ich finde das auch sehr interessant, dass es hier das Bundesverwaltungsgericht ist und nicht etwa,
Verfassungsgericht, ich meine dessen Auseinandersetzung mit Überwachung ist ja,
nun schon weithin auch bekannt, wo da die Grundposition ist. Das Bundesverwaltung, ich weiß gar nicht, warum überhaupt das Verwaltungsgericht an dieser Stelle jetzt das Richtige Gericht war für so eine Sache.
Das weiß ich auch nicht. Ähm vielleicht äh ist das der geregelte Weg, damit er jetzt eine Verfassungsbeschwerde einreichen kann. Also wir brauchen irgendwann mal hier einen Juristen im Team.
Ja, das wäre äh ganz.
Ich frage mal den Herrn Hertig. Herting, meine Güte, ich ich komme da immer durcheinander. Nico Herting.
Verwaltungsgericht ist das Oberste Gericht der Bundesrepublik Deutschland in öffentlich-rechtlichen Streitigkeiten nicht verfassungsrechtlicher Art.
Aha und und neben dem Bundesarbeitsgericht Bundesgerichtshof, Finanzhof,
Bundessozialgericht, einer der fünf obersten Gerichtshöfe des Bundes. Also wir lernen, es gibt fünf höchste Gerichtshöfe. Das ist ja auch wieder was für,
Verschwörungstheoretiker und in diesem Fall ist es halt zuständig bei öffentlich rechtlichen Streitigkeiten,
die Definition dieses Begriffs. In diesem Kontext erspare ich mir jetzt mal.
Jura lernen mit Linus und Tim. Das.
Hm. Von Dummies.
Ja
Was so zu sagen?
Nee, nee, sie wollte das, ich wollte, ja, ich wollte eigentlich nur auf diese, auf diese Absurdität dieser Situation hinweisen.
Okay, damit haben wir dann auf die Absurdität dieser Situation hingewiesen.
Kommen wir zur nächsten absurden Situation.
Ja
Der BND darf nicht sagen, ob er Trojaner einsetzt. Das ist auch sehr schön. Der Andre Hunko, das ist einer von der Linkspartei, der immer das schöne äh Fragen stellt.
Hm
Ja? Ähm und der hat jetzt gefragt, ja wie ist denn das? Er würde jetzt mal ganz gerne wissen ähm.
Wie sich das denn so verhält mit den ganzen Trojanern, ne, nach seitdem jetzt der digital äh Trojaner vom äh CCC hochgenommen wurde. Würde ihn jetzt mal interessieren, wie oft haben denn Behörden des Inneren,
der Verteidigung,
oder des Bundeskanzleramtes in den Jahren zweitausendzwölf und zweitausenddreizehn Trojaner zum Eindringen und Abhören fremder Computersysteme in Klammern auch mobil,
In und Ausland eingesetzt. Er würde das dann gerne noch trennen nach der Onlinedurchsuchung, also dem der Volltrojanisierung, wo dann dein Rechner komplett durchsucht wird, wie ein Haus.
Und der Quellen-TKÜ, also dem Trojaner, der nur zu dem Zwecke installiert wird, ähm oder vorgeblich nur zu dem Zwecke installiert wird, dich äh bei der,
äh bei dem äh bei dem Verfassen verschlüsselter Nachrichten zu überwachen. Das heißt, du du nutzt ihn wie PGP oder,
oder OTR oder oder Skype oder irgendwas, was die nicht, was die nicht im Klartext abhören können, wie die E-Mails, die du versendest über die Deutsche Telekom. Ähm,
dann wollen sie deinen Computer trojanisieren, um dir quasi beim Tippen zusehen zu können, bevor dir die Nachricht verschlüsselt. Das ist ja die Quellentheke,
Das würde er gerne aufgeschlüsselt haben und dann auch die die jeweiligen Behörden, wer da wie was gemacht hat,
und dann interessiert ihn noch mit welchen Aufträgen und Dienstleistungen private Firmen in diesem Bereich versehen sind.
Und da wurde ihm halt, äh wurde ihm dann geantwortet, von der ähm Bundesregierung, ja ähm.
Auskunft über die Anzahl der durch den Bundesnachrichtendienst eingesetzten Trojaner ist geheimhaltungsbedürftig, denn
Die Antwort erhält Informationen zum Umfang der eingesetzten
nachrichtendienstlichen Mittel und lässt Rückschlüsse sowohl auf die Arbeitsweise, als auch über die als auch auf die eingesetzte nachrichtendienstliche Technik des Bundesnachrichtendienstes zu,
Deswegen können sie da nichts zu sagen.
Großartig.
Also,
bereits die Information, ob beziehungsweise in welchem Umfang der Bundesnachrichtendienst Trojaner einsetzt, kann zu einer wesentlichen Schwächung der Aufgabenerfüllung führen.
Und das ist wieder genau das Gleiche, ne. Es äh und das stimmt ja, sie haben ja sogar Recht. Sie haben ja also es stimmt ja, es ist halt äh nur interessant so, dass sie,
meinen mit dieser Begründung gerichtlich durchzukommen in Zeiten, wo uns langsam einleuchtet, dass wir ein bisschen mehr Transparenz über geheimnisliche Tätigkeiten brauchen, ja?
Ich freue mich, worin diese äh Schwächungen dann letzten Endes eigentlich bestehen dürfte. Also,
geben, dass sie das Ding überhaupt nicht einsetzen, das falls es irgendwie nicht technisch gebacken bekommen, dass sie dann sozusagen vor ihren äh Schlapphutkumpels da äh Scheiße dastehen, ja und dann immer aufm Pausenhof irgendwie ausgemeckert werden,
ob sich irgendwie in einem Maße abspielt, wo irgendwie gar kein Halt mehr ist.
Oder dass sie das sagen und dann irgendwie von der Firma äh zur Kasse gebeten werden, die irgendein Dealer, dass sie quasi pro Einsatz eine Lizenz abdrücken müssen oder einen zweiten Wahnsinn.
Scheiße, da müssen wir nachzahlen.
Nee, das können wir jetzt nicht sagen und so.
Da müssen wir nachzählen, dann ist unser Budget aufgebraucht.
Ein paar da müssen wir noch ein paar Groschen nachschmeißen.
Ja, aber ähm was sie dann noch äh äh rausrücken ist für projektbezogene Aufgaben im Kompetenz äh Zentrum
Informationstechnische Überwachung erbringen die Firmen CSC Deutschland Solutions GmbH und GmbH GmbH
Beratungsleistungen. Äh die CSC, das hatte ich ja schon vor einiger Zeit mal,
in meinem kleinen Vortrag da beim dreißig C drei auch betont, ähm die machen ja noch andere Sachen, ne, die haben ja auch D-Mail gemacht,
und sind also weiterhin dabei, äh hier den den Staatstrojaner ähm.
Mit weiterzuentwickeln oder daran zu wirken, dass er irgendwie verfassungskonform wird oder was auch immer. Und äh for soft ist irgendwie eine Seite, die sagen, sie wachen äh also so eine typische,
IT-Firma, ne? Software, Architektur, steht für,
weiß jetzt nicht genau, warum steht ja.
Darf auch nicht bekannt geben, dass das darf auch nicht bekannt gegeben werden, das könnte zu einer erheblichen Schwächung des Unternehmens führen.
Das ist so geil ey, das sind so diese typischen Unternehmen. Das ist irre, was die meinen. Das ist 4soft ist bekannt für die Standards V-Modell XT-Bund und KBL, die wir entscheidend mitgeprägt haben. Darunter prangert dann das Logo des Tiffy,
Ja, also das sind so die, das TÜV-Süd-Strey. Ja, das sind so diese diese Firmen.
Standards, die uns täglich begleiten.
Das sind Standards, die uns täglich begleiten. Wir wissen's nur nicht. Wir können's nur nicht beweisen. Wir können's nur nicht beweisen.
Es darf halt auch keine Auskunft fließen.
Solche Läden, ey, schön, schön, ja, toll, also ich finde das auch immer wichtig, solche Firmen an den Pranger zu ziehen, das ist wirklich,
Ähm allein schon um um äh fähige Menschen, die irgendwo anders Jobs bekommen könnten, da äh davor zu warnen, äh sich jemals mit diesen,
Firma einzulassen. Also zu CSD ist natürlich noch nur der Vollständigkeit halber, falls er schon in Vergessenheit geraten ist, zu sagen, dass die äh
die amerikanische Mutterfirma einer der äh Hauptzulieferer für die NSA ist, ja, was äh natürlich dann auch in Deutschland ähm vor einigen Monaten schon,
die berechtigte Frage aufwarf, ob man die Jungs ausgerechnet, denen jetzt irgendwie ähm,
in den Kern der Deutschen äh Sicherheitsinfrastruktur äh lassen möchte, wo sie dann äh Standards verhunzen und äh Staatstrojaner schreiben.
Aber das jetzt das CSC aber in diesem Trojanergeschäft mit verwickelt ist, ist jetzt auch keine wirklich neue Information. Das wurde in diesem Zusammenhang nur nochmal wiederholt.
Genau. Bevor man mir aber das da äh äh bevor ich da eine äh Anzeige bekomme, wegen falsch aushaare, möchte ich darauf hinweisen, dass ähm,
nach mir öffentlich bekannten Quellen nur mit der Qualitätssicherung oder Code Audit äh ähm befasst war und nicht mit der Entwicklung.
Hm. Ja. Schön.
Gehen wir doch mal weiter. Da hatten wir dann auch neulich eine Meldung aus Großbritannien. Das war in der vorletzten Sendung, sehe ich das richtig.
Glaube sogar, er ist in.
War sogar schon die letzte. Die Zeit vergeht äh ja immer so schnell, ne? Man weiß es ja nicht.
Ich glaube, es war die vorletzte, nee.
Ähm wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall geht es um dieses äh DIP,
äh Projekt, wo halt Großbritannien ähm vorhat, so eine Art Notfall, äh also im Rahmen einer Not äh Notfallgesetz ähm,
Notfall oder Notstands äh Überwachungsgesetz äh zu beschließen. Genau das war in der letzten Sendung. Jetzt habe ich's auch. Und äh siehe da, äh der Notfall ist hier offensichtlich schnell genug eingetreten,
und das ist jetzt auch schon durchgewunken worden, richtig?
Genau, das ist jetzt beschlossene Sache. Und es ist jetzt erstmal unklar,
Großbritannien nicht vielleicht gegen EU Recht verstoßen hat, weil sie ja diese gesetzliche Neuregelung eines unter EU-Kompetenz fallenden Sachverhalts,
nämlich dieser Überwachung ähm.
Und Vorratsdatenspeicherung während ihres Eilverfahrens von irgendwie acht Tagen, indem sie das Gesetz da durchgeprügelt haben und zwar von allen drei großen Parteien, ja
ähm,
nicht äh äh rechtzeitig der EU-Kommission zur Prüfung vorgelegt haben, ja. Es ist ja nicht so, als könnte ein EU-Mitglied einfach irgendwas beschließen, ohne dass vorher mal der EU-Kommission zum abnicken zu geben und in diesem Fall wäre das ja sicherlich auch,
gar nicht so schlecht gewesen. Ähm die.
Irgendein Gesetz beschließen, aber nicht unbedingt eins, äh, dessen Thematik jetzt äh ganz oder teilweise in den Bereich EU-Kompetenz.
Also wo es unter Umständen eine Regulation gibt und wo es ja in diesem Fall auch sehr wohl äh auch eine Beschlusslage äh gibt, also zumindest das EuGH. Das ist nämlich mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung alles äh gar nicht so toll ist.
So ist es und hm also quasi,
dieses Schnellverfahren als solches überhaupt erst mal anzugreifen, das macht die Bürgerrechtsorganisation Excess.
Ähm die haben also jetzt diese diese Prüfung ähm eingeleitet ähm ob ob nicht eben gegen äh,
gegen dieses EU Recht verstoßen wurde. Allein durch diesen schnellen Beschluss. Und ähm zwei Abgeordnete, nämlich,
David Davis von den Konservativen und Tom Watson von der Labour Party ähm haben zusammen mit der Bürgerrechtsorganisation Liver Team,
Klage gegen dieses gesamte Gesetz,
eingereicht, weil sie nämlich davon ausgehen, dass es äh gegen die europäische Menschenrechtskonvention und gegen die,
Grundrechtskater der Europäischen Union verstößt und sie haben natürlich auch ähm das äh als äh absurd und beleidigend äh getadelt, das
eben als Notstandsgesetz kurz vor der parlamentarischen äh Sommerpause eingebracht und damit diesen,
wilden äh Gewalt äh Drohungen, also wir werden alle sterben, äh da durchgeprügelt wurde.
So, das heißt, wir werden jetzt mal hoffentlich sehen, äh dass.
Der Hykord, vor dem sie klagen, äh hoffentlich damit irgendwie.
Nochmal bricht mit diesem, mit diesem Vorhaben, was da jetzt schon beschlossene Sache ist.
Es ist wirklich äh das ist wirklich irre, ja. Du stehst da ja und staunst einfach nur, ne. Kam aus dem Nichts, schnell in Notstand gesetzt, zack, bumm und jetzt müssen die halt irgendwie vor den klagen und ja, ich hoffe, dass das wenigstens schnell geht.
Also vor dem Britanniens,
Mhm,
Ja, ist äh äh wirklich interessant, wie man da jetzt so in dieser Kurzfristig, also warum man überhaupt jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt drauf gekommen ist, erschließt sich ohnehin niemanden.
Aber offensichtlich sollte hier einfach mal der also ich deute das mal so ein bisschen als Versuch äh hier noch irgendwelche Nägel mit Köpfen zu machen bevor diese EuGH-Regelung in irgendeiner Form noch weiter um sich greift.
Wird man sehen, wie viel Erfolg sie äh damit haben. Ja, kommen wir nach Österreich,
Da gab's ja vorher nicht allzu langer Zeit. Ich glaube, das ist so ein Jahr her oder so, anderthalb Jahre, ja, als so die äh Schließung von Kino Punkt T O anstand, dass also diese Webseite, die halt so wie's ihr so gepasst hat
genommen hat, also quasi Kopien von von Filmen, für die sie keine Ausstrahlungsrechte besaßen und die eben dann auf so einer Webseite als Streaming,
ähm Server angeboten haben. Die Butze ist dann dicht gemacht worden und ja.
Betreiber sind äh glaube ich teilweise in den Knast gegangen, ne.
Die sind auch, ja, genau, also die haben da sozusagen durchaus auch persönlichen Schaden äh davongetragen. Im Einzelnen weiß ich's jetzt nicht mehr so ganz genau, wie sich das bei denen dann entwickelt hat, aber,
es gab dann eine Klage und zwar von Konstantin Film,
Die man ja auch schon so ein bisschen äh kennt, weil sie sie noch immer ein bisschen den Nackenhaare hochgehen. Also und dann immer versuchen ähm die Verbreitung des Hitlermehms äh im Internet zu verhindern.
Oh Mann e.
Großem Erfolg, ja, also egal.
Also ich weiß nicht, Hitlermehr ist, glaube ich, die falsche Bezeichnung, oder? Also du meinst das Untergang im Leben?
Von. Na ja gut, aber ich meine, also das Mehmen ist bekannt als Hitler-Reacts.
Hitler Hitler Reacts, genau. Hitler Reacts. Das ist.
Also das ist aber mal so der Primärname und ich meine, es gibt in dem Sinne kein anderes Hitler-Mememen, also das ist einfach das Hitler-Mehen und äh ja und die Frage ist, was was würde Hitler sagen, ja,
hören würde, dass äh die also hier äh auch gegen ähm ja, gegen TV Kabelnetz,
Betreiber, ne, warte mal, die haben geklagt, also Konstantin Film und die Filmproduktion ist mega, hatten geklagt gegen ein Kabelnetzbetreiber und zwar konkret UPC Austria, äh,
weil die, also der Kabelnetzbetreiber, in seiner Aufgabe als Internetservice Provider muss man dazu sagen.
Genau, weil der in seiner Aufgabe als.
Betreiber, ne? Genau.
Der in seiner Aufgabe als Internetbetreiber nicht äh den Zugang zu KinoTO sperren wollte, auf ihr Geheiß.
Ja, also auf ihren Straßen liefen diese Daten und äh sie wollten da nicht sperren und ihr seid ja total äh bekloppt so.
Genau und sie hatten.
Also die Frage, um die es jetzt dreht, sich's dreht, ist, seit äh dem Urteil vom EUGH im März zweitausendvierzehn, Lokbuchnetzpolitik berichtete, können Internetservice Provider,
grundsätzlich erstmal verpflichtet werden, illegale Webseiten zu sperren. Das war ja das Urteil des EUGH und ähm,
Da wurden aber jetzt, wurde jetzt nicht genauer beschrieben, wie denn das vonstatten zu gehen habe. Und jetzt wurde halt dieser,
gerichtliche Auseinandersetzung zwischen Konstantin und Wega auf der einen Seite und UPC Austria auf der anderen Seite ähm,
vor dem oberen, obersten Gerichtshof Österreichs äh zu Ende gestritten und das Urteil, das dort gefällt wurde, liest sich jetzt so, dass.
Webseiten zu sperren sind, die vermeintlich illegale Inhalte bereitstellen. Und jetzt zitiere ich die Interpretation der äh ISPA, der Internetservice Providers of Austria,
oder ich sage mal, istpa. Äh dieses Urteil jetzt gelesen haben und sagen, na ja,
Das heißt, wir werden verpflichtet, vermeintlich illegale Inhalte zu sperren und zwar dann die gesamte Seite,
Ein Nachweis muss der rechte Inhaber so wie jetzt geurteilt wurde dazu nicht erbringen,
Es reicht die Behauptung, dass seine Rechte verletzt werden. Und auch wenn der Provider sich weigert,
und dann eine Klage stattfindet und ihren normalen Weg geht, findet keine Prüfung statt,
Das heißt, der Provider müsse sich erst zu einer Beugestrafe verurteilen lassen,
und gegen diese Beugestrafe Berufung einlegen.
Damit dann endlich die inhaltliche Richtigkeit der Speeraufforderung überprüft werden könnte.
Das ist ja super. Also mit anderen Worten, jeder kann irgendwie daherkommen und sagen, hier auf.
Genau, auf der Standard Punkt äh AT äh wurde wurde mein Logo missbraucht,
nimmt das Ding mal vom Netz.
Vom ja.
Das ist ja im Prinzip so, ne, also ich habe da irgendwas gesehen, das sah so ähnlich aus, wie was was ich äh ja, seit äh zwei Tagen auf meinem T-Shirt-Shop äh vertreibe und so geht's ja nun gar nicht.
Und der entscheidende Punkt ist hier natürlich, was die ISPA fordert und ich denke, das ist auch, denke ich, hier unbedingt richtig und wichtig, unabhängig jetzt davon, dass es wahrscheinlich nicht,
sie sich erst zu einer Beugestrafe verurteilen lassen müssen, um um dann Berufung einlegen müssen, ja? Also ich denke, da,
Interpretieren sie das ähm,
Das Urteil sehr wörtlich, wie es sich wahrscheinlich in der Realität dann nicht mehr abspielen würde, aber sie zeigen, was die Realität sein wird. Das zeigen sie schon sehr genau, nämlich dass es genau darauf hinauslaufen wird, dass irgendeiner sagt, ey Sperma und die Provider sagen, okay, machen wir.
So und sie fordern,
ein Richter über Internetsperren zu entscheiden habe. Was ja nun wirklich, mal ganz ehrlich, so dass das absolute,
Minimum,
Ja, wenn du schon sagst, irgendwie, hier sollen jetzt Webseiten gesperrt werden, dann aber doch wenigstens bitte mit Richter verfügen. Auch eine Richterverfügung ist am Ende natürlich dann nichts wert, ne? Die ist ja dann, die werden ja auch im im ähm.
Freitagnachmittag kurz vor Schluss nochmal wegmacht, genau. Das kennen wir ja im Prinzip auch schon aus der ganzen Überwachungsfrage
der Richter vorbehalt, ja, der dann immer auch äh in der Diskussion so das Argument ist mit, na ja, was wollen sie denn? Äh ein Richter hat ja darüber entschieden, ja und das äh sieht dann so in der Realität eben so aus, dass er so ein äh
so ein Zeichen äh äh Block vor die Nase bekommt, wo er sich dann für Seite für Seite durchblättern darf, um da äh den Friedrich Wilhelm abzusetzen und dann
geht's halt in die Datsche und da wird halt nichts durchgelesen, da wird einfach abgewunken und äh abgezeichnet und fertig, sonst wär's halt auch einfach in der Masse überhaupt
gar nicht äh zu leisten so. Aber noch nicht einmal dieses Minimum, ne.
Genau, noch nicht einmal dieses Minimum dazukommen noch beim Richter Vorbehalt, dass äh die das gemeine ist ja nicht nur, dass der
das alles lesen oder nicht lesen muss, ja?
Und da irgendwie seinen seinen drunter schreibt und einen Stempel dran macht, sondern dass die Alternative zu nicht unterschreiben ist, dass er,
ablehnt und ausführlich begründet, ja. Das heißt, er hat von der allein von der Arbeit her,
einen sehr starken Anreiz da einfach den Stempel drunter zu machen, weil die Alternative ist.
Genau, eigentlich müsste.
Seine DIN A4 Seite zu schreiben oder machst du jetzt einfach den scheiß Stempel und.
Genau, eigentlich müssen sie nämlich andersrum oder zumindest auf gleicher Höhe sein. Also entweder müsste beides im selben Maße begründet werden. Das ist sozusagen der selbe Arbeitsaufwand ist, ja? Oder man könnte halt auch sagen, ein Richter kann das jederzeit ablehnen,
aber wenn das bestätigt muss warum. Aber ich würde halt sagen, irgendwie in beiden Fällen, ne,
wäre dann ohnehin nochmal eine interessante Drossel. Also findet hier alles nicht statt. Klingt auch ehrlich gesagt für äh uns juristische Laien ähm,
Ausreichend skandalös, dass man das also zumindest mal gepflegt die Nase drüber rümpfen durfte,
und ja, die Ice Piece machen so einen leicht angefressenen Eindruck. Ich weiß aber nicht, wie groß da die Wut in Österreich äh schon ist, ja, also das äh ist mir vollkommen unklar
Wäre auf jeden Fall sehr angemessen da mal ein wenig sich aufzuplustern,
Ja, sehr viel mehr ist da jetzt nicht passiert. Was was soll da jetzt passieren?
Ja, da müssen wir jetzt erst mal gucken. Ich meine, das ist ja schon äh der äh oberste Gerichtshof da, ne? Also das ist ähm.
Ich bin ähm gespannt, äh ich meine diese die sind jetzt erstmal,
ratlos, ja, was sollen sie denn machen? Also sie haben jetzt erstmal dieses Urteil und ähm.
Sie sind da jetzt sehr, sehr mit unglücklich.
Argumentieren natürlich auch so mit dieser äh löschen äh statt Sperren äh Idee.
Ja. Nach wie vor ein starkes Argument, wie ich finde.
Ja gut, ich meine, man kann natürlich jetzt zum Verfassungs äh Gerichtshof äh marschieren.
In Österreich und äh mal äh abklopfen, was es denn mit mit so einer Rechtslage auf sich hat. Ich kann mir ehrlich gesagt nicht so recht vorstellen, dass das Bestand haben kann unter diesen Bedingungen, weil es im Prinzip, ich meine, du musst nicht begründen warum,
Ja, also du musst es nur behaupten, du musst es überhaupt nicht darlegen und dann sollen andere Entitäten auf einmal.
Firmen
sollen Maßnahmen ergreifen, gegen die sie noch nicht mal Einspruch erheben können? Also ich meine, da fehlt da irgendwie so ein so ein bisschen dieser Aspekt Rechtsstaat für mich. Also da ist ja irgendwie so ein vollkommenes Missverhältnis der Kräfte, wenn man das jetzt mal auf andere Bereiche
Äh äh macht, dann ist das so ein bisschen so diese
typisch US-amerikanische Verhaftungs äh Politik, ja, du bist halt irgendwie in so einem Supermarkt, dann kommt irgendwie einer auf dich zu und sagt, der hat was geklaut, so, ja und äh in Abhängigkeit so von,
ja, der weiß nicht, dann wird halt die Polizei gerufen und dann wirst du halt auch erstmal eingeknastet und dann sitzt du da halt so äh
paar Tage bis zu deiner Verhandlung, wo du dann überhaupt das allererste Mal eine Chance hast, dich da überhaupt zu äh zu äußern, ja, zu dem Zeitpunkt bist du aber dann in deiner Firma auch schon entlassen worden,
und musste ja irgendwie äh Geld sorgen von deinen äh Freunden, so du noch welche hast, äh um dich da überhaupt erstmal wieder ins Freigesetz zu sehen. Also das ist das ist ja, das ist ja Realität und
nicht die einzige Realität, aber auf jeden Fall 'ne gängige und sichtbare Realität und von diesem Geschmäckle hat das halt hier so 'n bisschen was für mich, also ich
finde das äh ausreichend, äh dass man sich da ordentlich mal drüber bussen sollte. Und ich verstehe nicht so ganz
was äh hier den OGH da geritten hat.
Die neue OGH hat geritten, dass sie ja sogar die haben nochmal sich beim Europäischen Gerichtshof versichert,
mit anhand einer juristischen Frage, die sie dann vorgelegt haben, ja? Und der EuGH hat die ja sogar beantwortet und hat gesagt, ja, Provider können dazu verpflichtet werden, illegale Webseiten zu sperren.
Das war grob die Antwort des EUGH. Und dann hat der österreichische OGH eben gesagt, ja, ist klar, dann machen wir das doch.
Nur als erst den EuGH sozusagen und dann in UGH.
Der OGH, der der der österreichische,
Obere ist der Gerichtshof hat den EuGH damit den Europäischen Gerichtshof gefragt, wie meint denn ihr euer Kram da genau, sag mal was dazu und dann hat der EuGH, dem OGH gesagt,
Folgendes.
Ja
Ja. Also da ich ich bin da jetzt äh wir sind wieder beim Jura lernen. Das äh ist jetzt ähm also ich kann jetzt auch.
Ja in welche Richtung auch immer gegangen ist, ist es jetzt einfach mal eine eine Rechtsauffassung, die sich hier widerspiegelt, die halte ich zumindest für, naja, hinterfragenswürdig und äh,
scheint mir so ein bisschen so ein gute Steilvorlage zu sein, da auch auch auf Verfassungsebene mal ein bisschen Welle zu machen,
Dieser Verband der Internetserviceprovida in Österreich, da äh ausreichend Werbe verspürt, das auch zu machen. Weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung. Wäre mal ganz interessant da auch mal eine Meinung einzuholen. Ähm werden wir sehen.
Ja, also ähm an dieser Stelle äh zeigt sich, dass man manchmal dann doch äh Seit an Seid mit den Providern äh kämpft.
Ja, absolut. Ich meine, in Deutschland.
Gibt es nicht in jeder Debatte, aber in vielen Debatten habe ich schon immer auch den Eindruck gehabt, dass das so die Provider Fraktion.
Problematik doch schon besser versteht, als manch andere Bäume. Ja, also auch,
ähnliche äh Verbände waren ja,
zum Beispiel in der äh Sperrdiskussion löschen statt Sperrdiskussion ja auch ganz klar positioniert, dass sie das halt einfach als,
Quatsch ansehen und auch die Skepsis, die generell der Vorratsdatenspeicherung entgegenschlug, ja?
Ist jetzt nicht so gewesen, dass sie jetzt wirklich damit Schildern durch die Straße gelaufen sind, aber dass sie das alles ähm abgenickt äh hätten, dem ist ja nun wirklich auch nicht so.
Wäre ja auch noch schöner, ja, wenn ausgerechnet so so eine so eine Branche, die jetzt auch wirklich so direkt aus dieser Digitalkultur äh erwachsen ist, äh da nach so wenigen Jahren auch schon äh anfängt, irgendwie nur noch äh
Lehrer durchs Hirn zu schieben, das wäre noch schöner. Na ja
Aber es wird ja alles gut, denn äh blühende Landschaften stehen äh ins Haus. Die Bundesregierung
hat ja angekündigt irgendwie eine digitale Agenda zu entwerfen und das kann ja nur eine Folge haben, ja? Das also alle Probleme gelöst werden
Schlaraffenland eigentlich so, die die Vorzüge äh von Digitalien in unsere,
stopfen, oder?
Ja, wir haben äh bei Netzpolitik Org wurde vor einigen Tagen dann jetzt der,
ein Entwurf zu dieser digitalen Agenda äh veröffentlicht, der jetzt schon seit einiger Zeit ähm zirkulierte. Der ist ähm,
sehr äh,
schwierig zu lesen, weil er, wie gesagt, halt blühende Landschaften verspricht. Ähm immer nur drin steht, was alles gefördert werden soll und was dann toll wird und ähm wie wichtig das alles ist,
ähm ich habe mehrmals versucht, den zu lesen. Das ging aber irgendwie nicht, weil ich dann immer weg bin zwischendurch,
Ich hab aber zumindest einen Punkt mir rausgesucht auf den ich dann mal eingehen würde beziehungsweise den hat der Ulf Buhrmeier rausgesucht.
Weil das auch sein Thema ist, nämlich die äh Störerhaftung. Ja, wir haben nämlich auch da letzte Woche schon drüber gesprochen, deswegen finde ich das ja,
ganz schön dann nochmal auch,
den Faden wieder aufzunehmen. Ähm die Störerhaftung, also das Problem, dass ich äh habe, wenn ich jemand anderem ein WLAN zur Verfügung stelle, der dann darüber beispielsweise ein äh,
an einem teilnimmt, in dem Material vorhanden ist, dass irgendjemand meint, äh dass es seine Rechte verletzen würde, damit sich äh.
Oder genötigt fühlt mir eine Abmahnung zu senden und ich dann,
nichts habe, um dieser Abmahnung ernsthaft entgegenzutreten, weil ich eben,
als Störer mithaftet, denn schließlich habe ich ja überhaupt dafür gesorgt, dass es einen Internetzugang gab, ähm der dieser äh der diesen Missetäter zur Verfügung stand. Äh und der deswegen eben,
hafte. Daher ja auch Störerhaftung ähm gegen die eben die äh Freifunnker jetzt auch klagen wollen. Ähm.
Und da weiß der Ulf ja auch seit einiger Zeit immer wieder darauf hin, habe ich ja alles letzte Woche schon erzählt, dass es ein Provider-Privileg gibt in Absatz äh Paragraph acht, Absatz eins des Ziele Mediengesetzes. Ähm,
denn das nach dem Wortlaut des Gesetzes,
für alle gilt. Und das heißt also für kommerzielle Provider wie die Deutsche Telekom ebenso wie für nebenbei Provider, also die Freifunnkar äh Cafes und Hotels.
Die anderen Wählern zur Verfügung stellen. So und jetzt gab es im,
Koalitionsvertrag der großen Koalition im vergangenen Herbst ähm ein ein Absatz, der,
lautete,
Die Potentiale von lokalen Funknetzwerken klammern WLAN als Zugang zum Internet im öffentlichen Raum müssen ausgeschöpft werden.
Wir wollen, dass in deutschen Städten mobiles Internet über WLAN für jeden verfügbar ist. Wir werden die gesetzlichen Grundlagen für die Nutzung dieser öffentlichen Netze,
deren Anbieter schaffen. Rechtssicherheit für WLAN-Betreiber ist dringend geboten, etwa durch Klarstellung der Haftungsregelungen.
Wunderbar.
Ist doch schön, ja? Ja, endlich das mal geklärt, das steht noch in Klammern hinter analog zu Excess Providern. Wobei, wie gesagt, das Gesetz diesen Unterschied heute schon nicht kennt. Ähm.
Den WLAN-Betreiber sind ja Excess-Provider, sie Providen Access, aber äh na ja, jetzt findet sich ein sehr ähnlicher Satz,
ähm in der digitalen Agenda, man könnte sich fast vorstellen, dass da ein bisschen äh Kopierpaste noch mit dran ist,
an diesem äh neuen Satz, ja, äh wo es der nämlich genauso lautet, mobiles Internet über WLAN soll künftig für jeden und jede Idee verfügbar sein, erste Änderung. Wir schaffen Rechtssicherheit bei,
öffentlichen Zugang zu lokalen Funknetzen, indem wir klarstellen und da ändert sich der Satz nämlich jetzt, dass die Anbieter solcher WLANs im öffentlichen Bereich beispielsweise Flughäfen, Hotels, Cafés,
oder als Access-Provider von der Haftung freigestellt sind,
Einen entsprechenden Gesetzesentwurf werden wir im August zweitausendvierzehn vorlegen. Das ist nächsten Monat. So, da haben sie's jetzt quasi wieder ähm.
So formuliert, dass es sich so liest, dass sie da sehr wohl irgendein Privileg für kommerzielle Anbieter ähm.
Schaffen möchten. Und das ist natürlich sehr spannend, weil dann würde es effektiv bedeuten, dass sie den aktuellen ähm,
im Gesetz geregelten ähm.
Die aktuell im Gesetz geregelte Haftungsbefreiung, die ja nur durch dieses Gerichtsurteil zum.
Sommer ein Märchensommer oder sowas, wie hieß diese, das ist so ein ganz äh irgendwas ein Sommer, Sommer unseres Lebens, genau. Sommer unseres Lebens war da dieser Film, um zu dem das ähm,
äh
Bundesgerichtshof damals so ein das verheerende Urteil gefällt hat, indem er sagte, Störerhaftung gilt bei äh offenen WLANs. Ja, da darauf begründet sich irgendwie dieser ganze Mist.
Ähm und.
Jetzt hieß es also, dass diese digitale Agenda an dem tatsächlichen Wortlaut des Gesetzes, der nur in letzter Zeit keine vernünftige Anwendung findet.
Eine Verschlechterung äh durchführen würde, nämlich dahingehend, dass der bisher geltende.
De facto durchgesetzte Gerichtsentscheidungsbrei dann auch äh zugesetzt zum tatsächlich geltenden Gesetz wird, ist das verständlich? Nee, ne? Das hätte man einfacher sagen können.
Ein bisschen vielleicht.
Okay, also Gesetz sagt eigentlich, äh Befreiung von Störerhaftungen gilt für alle, die anderen Internet geben.
In der Rechtssprechung wird aber allgemein einfach immer gesagt, gilt für alle, die anderen Internet für Geld geben.
Und die digitale Agenda soll nun das Recht dahin ändern, dass es für alle gilt, die anderen Internet für Geld geben. Das heißt, de facto wird sich nichts ändern.
Und äh.
Äh nicht unbedingt für, nicht unbedingt für Geld, sondern in dem Moment, wo man quasi eine kommerzielle Identität,
darstellt, ja? Also auch wenn jetzt die Bahn WLAN in der DB Lounge kostenlos bereitstellt, wäre sie trotzdem von der Störerhaftung,
ausgenommen. Ich meine, das ist ganz klar hier die Intention, dass man irgendwie immer noch diese Unterscheidung machen möchte zwischen die Wirtschaft, weil der muss ja geholfen werden. Und die Zivilgesellschaft, ja, das sind ja alles äh potentielle äh Kopierverbrecher
die können wir ja jetzt nicht gleich alle laufen lassen. Obwohl das eigentlich auch de facto so von der gerichtlichen Entscheidungslage ohnehin ja schon mehr als nur bröckelt.
Genau, da würde ich nämlich jetzt nochmal darauf hinweisen auf die, auf deinen auf, auf das Kämpfen der Provider, Seit an Seit mit den Aktivisten, denn die Provider haben natürlich,
ein klares Interesse, dass es genau so wird, dass man nämlich sagt, ja, Störerhaftung.
Mit uns nicht so.
Ausnahme für uns haben.
Genau, damit wir in den Cafés das äh anbieten können.
Wir möchten nicht, dass auf einmal alle von der Störerhaftung befreit sind, weil dann würde ja einfach jede Sau ihr WLAN aufmachen für alle,
Auf einmal hätten alle überall Internet, ja, der,
Daten-Traffic äh bei T-Mobile O2 E Plus und Vodafone ginge in den Keller. Weil alle sich einfach nur noch in die schnelleren WLANs ähm ihrer Umgebung einbuchen. Niemand müsste mehr haften, alles wäre,
toll und es bräche eigentlich dieses gesamte Geschäftsmodell äh WLAN-Hotspots anbieten, auf einmal wieder in sich zusammen?
Ja, das würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, weil eigentlich die WLAN-Hotspots eigentlich in dem Moment wirklich immer interessant sind, wo man einfach in in schwierigen Orten ist, wo es in der Regel keinerlei private Optionen äh gibt. Ja, also ich meine, Hotspots haben.
In anderen Ländern anders, das ist in anderen Ländern anders. Ähm in den USA zum Beispiel, da hast du sehr viel mehr offene WLANs. Also es waren ja erst auch tatsächlich diese.
Ja, aber auf auf einer.
Teile, die dazu geführt haben, dass die WLANs alle geschlossen wurden.
Aber auf einer Messe,
oder äh an einem Bahnhof, ja, im Flugzeug et cetera. Das sind halt so die Momente, wo man wirklich auch danach äh giert im Zug und äh im Zug hilft ja halt äh nicht, wenn irgendwie jetzt am Bahndamm jemand mal äh für
Komma zwei Millisekunden dir kurz da dein dein WLAN äh in den Zug reinstrahlt. Also das.
Okay, das das mag sein, dass das für dich jetzt die Anwendungsfälle sind. Ähm für mich wäre das durchaus von Interesse ähm
sagen wir mal, in den an Orten, wo ich mich aufhalte, die jetzt dann vielleicht nicht einen Flughafen oder ein Bahnhof oder ein Hotel sind, halt auch mal ein WLAN zu benutzen, ja. Das,
wäre einfach schön, ne. Ich, wie gesagt, ich habe ja auch schon mal äh erklärt, dass ich das auch mache, dass ich ja auch WLAN
teile, beziehungsweise im Moment habe ich's ausgeschaltet.
Bin eben auch dazu gezwungen, dass dann eben nochmal irgendwo durchzuschieben, damit damit nicht ich nachher einen auf den Sack bekomme.
Ich teile mein mein Fehlern mit jedem.
Das stimmt nicht. Du hast deine sind alle zu.
Ja, das.
Ist ja auch richtig so. Ich meine, ist ist eine ist äh hat ja auch andere Gründe, warum man sein WLAN vielleicht nicht unbedingt offen betreiben möchte, weil äh man dadurch ja auch sich ähm.
Einfängt, Angriffe äh einfängt, äh potenzielle Sicherheitslücken einfängt.
Genau, man funkt halt seinen eigenen Traffic, die größtenteils unverschlüsselt durch die Gegend und äh wenn der kleine Nachbar dann da mal den Wire Shark anmacht, dann äh.
Ja gut, ich meine, mittlerweile haben ja eigentlich alle äh halbwegs ähm aktuellen Rauter so eine Gast-WLAN-Funktion, die bietet sich halt an der Stelle dann äh schon eher an,
Ja, also,
ja, die dann auch so die anderen Teilnehmer da auch ausblenden und so. Klar, weil das unverschlüsselt ist, ist es unverschlüsselt. Also es gibt da schon so einige äh Sachen. Also es wird jetzt nicht jeder gleich zum Sankt Georg, der so seinen WLAN-Mantel äh beliebig teilt, aber
äh ist klar, also es gibt natürlich sehr viele Situationen, wo man das eben sehr wohl möchte und wo das auch überhaupt kein Problem sein sollte,
ja also da finde ich ist jetzt irgendwie der Drops auch noch nicht gelutscht, das ist auf jeden Fall erforderlich da auch
in der Sommerpause einen Auge drauf zu haben, was denn die Bundesregierung da im Hinterzimmer noch an neuen Vorschlägen so äh herausbringt und da dann gegebenenfalls drauf einzuhauen.
Genauso machen wir's. Wir hauen drauf. Und sonst, Tim.
Äh sonst ist irgendwie Sommer, ne? Also ich habe hier auch so für den August so eine kleinere Sommerpause äh im Auge, wobei allerdings, glaube ich, unser,
Davon nur so am Rande tangiert wird, ja, also grade ein paar Termine gesetzt.
Werden wir ein bisschen.
Also es wird da vielleicht mal eine Woche oder zwei, aber auch nicht hintereinander. Ähm mal kein Programm sein. Wir werden das also hier weiter begleiten.
Hier ist kein Sommer, hier ist Monsun.
Ja, ist doch gut.
Ja, ist. Der ist auch schön, ne?
Ja, insofern gibt's wenig äh Neues zu verkünden. Die.
Ja, es gibt neue Sachen zu verkünden, aber die verkünden wir dann halt einfach bei der nächsten Folge Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Oh, ein Cliffhanger. Hm.
Ja. Bleiben sie dran.
Genau.
Werden ihre Grundrechte gerettet werden oder werden alle unsere Protagonisten in der Vollüberwachung untergehen. Schalten sie auch nächste Woche wieder ein, wenn es heißt, guten Morgen Tim.
Guten Morgen Linus.
Witzig.